on va plus loin avec nous en direct
aujourd'hui de Yaoundé c'est comme
chaque mardi à nos côtés Marie Roger
Billois bonjour Marie Roger
vous avez suivi à nos côtés il y a
quelques instants le discours qui a
prononcé depuis la tribune des Nations
Unies Emmanuel Macron lors de cette 77e
assemblée générale que vous suivez sans
doute depuis le début de la journée avec
nous et avec gauthierry binsky qui est
également à mes côtés bonjour Gauthier
on va écouter on va revenir sur un
extrait justement de cette allocution du
Président de la République écoutez-le
le 24 février dernier la Russie membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité a rompu
par un acte d'agression d'invasions et
d'annexion notre sécurité collective on
peut dire tout ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui
j'entends nombre de débats j'ai entendu
nombre de prises de parole
il est une chose sûre et certaine au
moment où je vous parle il y a des
troupes russes en Ukraine et à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas de troupe
ukrainienne en Russie
c'est un état de fait ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis le 24 février dernier
est un retour à l'âge des impérialismes
et des colonies
la France le refuse et recherchera
obstinément la paix et c'est au service
de cette position
que j'assume le dialogue conduit avec la
Russie
des avant le déclenchement de la guerre
tout au long des derniers mois et que je
continuerai de l'assumer
Marie Roger Billois en direct avec nous
de Yaoundé on l'a compris à une partie
de ce discours était destiné au pays qui
jusqu'à présent n'ont pas pris position
entre la Russie et disons l'Ukraine et
ses alliés occidentaux comme avez-vous
perçu ce discours depuis Yaoundé
et bien c'est une des meilleures
tentatives d'embarquer je dirais
tout le monde qui ne voulait pas
s'impliquer dans ce conflit dans et je
dirais l'histoire et l'universalité de
ce qui est en train de faire l'univers
l'universalité des Nations Unies et de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies
l'universalité des valeurs que devant
les amis les Nations Unies je crois
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de moments
importants et je crois que c'est un
discours qui restera bon maintenant
pour parler et faire les affirmations
sur les principes et donner une vision
et lorsqu'il dit
deux choses très importantes il
reconnaît les erreurs de ce qu'on
appelle le camp occidental mais et ça
c'est très important parce que tous les
arguments qu'on a entendu et Emmanuel
Macron montre et les a bien écouté on a
je crois que c'était un tableau complet
des réserves et de tout ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'entendre sur la question et
qui font que les Africains
voilà se sent le plus ou moins concerné
par tout ça il a su gérer les réengager
dans un processus qui est aussi à leur
avantage c'était très fort lorsqu'il a
dit bon voilà
non mais l'immense
c'était et pas
de souscrire à des invasions de
territoire c'était de avoir une
indépendance justement et également
lorsqu'il a dit que propose le modèle
qu'est-ce que nous propose cet ordre qui
serait à notre blanc avec dans la Russie
quels sont les valeurs que qui serait
offerte justement aux africains ou au
reste de soutien qui est un peu
sceptique je crois que ça c'est des
passages importants parce que quand il
dit voilà qu'il a bien écrit et
contrairement par exemple un rdal qui a
fait un très bon discours si on peut y
revenir mais qui c'est gardé de
décrire un peu ce café la Russie
d'attaquer la Russie je crois que
c'était très important de dire quels
sont les enjeux ici et pourquoi on ne
peut pas soutenir la guerre en Ukraine
vous vous le trouvez convaincant
lorsqu'il affume la Russie d'une volonté
impérialiste
par les Africains parlant des Africains
comme voilà
des politiques impérialistes mais comme
on l'a dit Macron ce n'est pas parce
qu'on se trompe ou qu'on applique pas
bien les principes que les principes
sont invités c'est important ça parce
que c'est exactement sur ça qu'on se
batte sur la question
c'est évidemment on a raison de rappeler
toutes les violations des États-Unis par
exemple de la France de qui on veut par
rapport à la souveraineté mais quand la
grande vous dit nous avons tort de
prendre nos libertés avec ces principes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut lui répondre bien
sûr qu'il a raison parce que surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on propose d'autres si ce
n'est
l'indépendance état le respect de la
souveraineté
respect je dirais de je dirais les
politiques des États de des
personnalités étatique etc dans les
relations internationales et on peut on
peut pas adopter comme mode juste parce
qu'on proteste contre les options
accepter qu'on envahisse des pays
indépendants juste parce qu'on est on
est en désaccord on est plus fort et
cetera il a raison de le dire je crois
que ça va faire débat et on va attendre
de voir
juste une chose aussi c'est que même si
on donne raison à Macron dans ce
discours là mais il faut aussi dire que
c'est grâce à la résistance un peu des
pays africains que il s'est senti époné
et qu'il est obligé de de sortir un
petit peu de ces retentions je crois que
ça a été utile que les pays africains
montrent qu'ils étaient qui regardent
toute cette évolution du monde et
regardez les politiques menées les
injustices de poids de mesure et qu'à un
moment donné tout ça se manifeste dans
des abstentions et et la connexion mais
ce n'est pas les solutions viables
gauthierry binsky les pays africains ou
disons ceux qui ne se sont pas alignés
ceux qui ont fait œuvre de neutralité
jusqu'à présent aurait relevé d'une
certaine manière le degré d'exigence des
gages d'une certaine manière à donner
face à la Russie vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
Emmanuel Macron dit que cette guerre
ouvre la voie à d'autres guerres
d'annexion finalement pour vous c'est
une évidence depuis le début oui parce
que regarder la séquence qu'on a connu
la Tchétchénie la deuxième guerre de
Tchétchénie la Géorgie l'annexion de la
Crimée et ce qui est intéressant dans ce
que dit Emmanuel Macron c'est que cet
ordre que prétend d'installer des
puissances comme la Russie et la Chine
en réalité c'est un désordre permanent
c'est-à-dire qu'on serait en permanence
suspendu au velléité des uns et des
autres qui dirait bah tiens voilà Jeanne
extrait volontiers
tout à fait et là où il pointe si vous
voulez quelque chose qui est aussi bien
dédié ou adressé à certains États du Sud
que on peut dire à certaines opinions en
Occident quand il dit
c'est un retour à l'âge des impérialisme
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours
affirmant qu'il fallait traduire
Vladimir Poutine en justice alors
Emmanuel Macron ne va pas aussi loin
mais cette phrase elle n'est pas
innocente on l'imagine dans son discours
non elle n'est pas innocente parce que
en plus si vous voulez beaucoup d'entre
nous vont dire c'est totalement
irréaliste ça n'est pas possible mais
souvenez-vous que on a dit la même
Vladimir Poutine cette phrase de
d'Emmanuel Macron d'après vous et le
vice sans le viser puisqu'il dit qu'il
va s'entretenir avec lui dans quelques
jours donc il y a une façon aussi
d'éviter le la confrontation mais ça
veut dire aussi que au motif que la
Russie est une puissance que c'est la
première puissance nucléaire il n'y a
pas de raison que ces citoyens qui le
premier soit dispensé échappe à cette
justice simplement il faut bien regarder
que pour compenser le sentiment
d'injustice dont il parle dans certains
pays il faut savoir aussi que les
États-Unis refusent ne reconnaissent pas
les instances internationales de
jugement et que donc ils échappent à
cette à cette justice donc il faudra
aussi
adapter les
on va écouter ce qu'a dit Macky Sall un
peu plus tôt dans la journée parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron est revenu dessus sur
la nécessaire réforme du Conseil de
sécurité Macky Sall il réclame lui un
siège aussi bien le nu d'ailleurs qu'au
G20 pour les pays l'Union africaine
écoutez-le et le temps de vaincre les
réticences
de construire
le narratif qui persiste à confiner
l'Afrique à la marge de cercle
décisionnel il est temps de faire droit
à la juste et légitime revendications
africaine sur la réforme du Conseil de
sécurité
tels que refléter dans le consensus
dans le même esprit
je rappelle notre demande
d'octroi d'un siège à l'Union africaine
au sein du G20
pour que l'Afrique puisse enfin se faire
représenter là où se prennent les
décisions qui engagent un milliard 400
millions d'Africains
cette demande à laquelle fait écho
Emmanuel Macron elle est devenue
incontournable il faut un siège
aujourd'hui à l'Afrique au Conseil de
sécurité
et bien si l'épisode
ukrainien doit avoir utilité d'abord
c'est celle de rappeler au monde
occidental que il a la responsabilité
d'appliquer les principes qui protègent
et deuxièmement dans ces principes il y
a une égalité une forme de justice à
rétablir pour que nous puissions bien
fonctionner ensemble ça fait très
longtemps qu'on demande une meilleure
place pour tout un continent
elle atteint une négociation aux Nations
Unies et je crois que là on est encore
dans une fenêtre historique où la chose
semble possible on espère que et Macky
Sall a extrêmement bien résumer la
situation parce que
c'est dans des
épisodes comme celui-là qu'il y a des
avances merci Marie Roger Billois merci
également Gauthier ribinski c'était on
va plus loin